there's been a lot of robots in movies
and our challenge was to do something
that was it was sort of fresh and unique
and in the comic books he took a couple
different forms he was at one point sort
of this bio mech cynthy dragon thing
that could turn also into a human being
with a bowler hat and but then he also
had a different kind of mech form and
while these were really really cool and
inventive I was concerned about how it
would fit in the world that we were
creating and so I the one of the first
research trip I did was a robotics
research trip and it was this it was the
week that Winnie the Pooh was released
in July of 2011 I was at MIT and Harvard
and Carnegie Mellon again just looking
for inspiration and one of our biz dev
artists coined the phrase huggable robot
she's like this robots gotta be huggable
sounds like alright she's gotta be
unique and huggable and he's got to be
everything so I you know I went on the
road and and did my research just
looking for inspiration in a huggable
robot and it was at Carnegie Mellon
University I met this guy by the name of
Chris Atkinson who is a researcher doing
research into soft robotics and I had
never heard of soft robotics before but
it blew me away and essentially what it
is is it's soft robots made of a
material like vinyl or something you
know pliable and filled with air and the
practical application for this
technology will be in the healthcare
industry in the future there'll be you
know robotic nurses and nurses aides and
that type of thing
and I had never seen anything like it
and Chris himself is actually a very
passionate roboticist much like we're
passionate about animation he's very
passionate about robotics and he started
going off on a bit of a rant and about
movies and how robots are portrayed in
movies and it's very frustrating to him
that robots are always the bad guy
it's always sort of you know technology
run amuck and and when no when is
somebody gonna put a robot on screen
that's the good guy that's the hero of
the story and it's like I finally
stopped and was like dude you had me at
vinyl trust me we won't let you down so
I was so taken by this technology that I
brought it back to the studio and said
art this is gonna be our robot and
and then it became about sort of
designing baymax and one of the other
things I learned on this trip was this
idea of the uncanny valley and it's
essentially like when machines or robots
specifically begin to get to human
looking they gets super creepy and we
didn't want baymax to be creepy we
wanted to be you know cool and nice and
gentle and compassionate so I had a
strong desire to keep him very simple in
design and also I felt like we have you
know some of the best animators on the
planet so we could give him you know a
paper bag and they'd be able to act with
it so and so I knew that they would be
up for the challenge so he never was
intended to have a face one of the
things we did think about is like did we
want him to have some sort of you know
screen where he might have a mouth that
would express or anything like that and
John wasn't too keen on the idea he just
thought it you know simpler you keep it
the better and so when I was in Tokyo I
was at a temple and I was looking up and
I saw these bells looking down at me and
I was awash with this feeling of
peacefulness and calm and that's kind of
what we wanted baymax to be to have this
effect on people and so snapped a couple
photos I just loved that idea of kind of
a circle with a line through it and I
brought it back to the studio and gave
it to our character designer she and Kim
and said there's his face he's like okay
Circle Circle Line done